pour la première fois depuis plusieurs
mois le drapeau bleu et jaune flotte aux
abords de l'imam
nous sommes le 1er octobre nous
déployons notre drapeau national et nous
le hissons sur notre terre à limon limon
sera ukrainienne
sur ces images fournies par le chef de
cabinet du président Zelenski c'est de
soldats symbolise l'avancée des forces
ukrainiennes ces dernières sont
parvenues à encercler les troupes russes
stationnés dans cette ville de la région
de deniersk selon le ministère ukrainien
de la défense les soldats de Kiev
entrent dans cette ville stratégique
l'iman est cruciale parce qu'il s'agit
de la prochaine étape vers la libération
du Dombas ukrainien et c'est très
important psychologiquement les quelques
5000 soldats russes en poste aliments
n'ont quitté la ville un retrait qui
pourrait marquer une nouvelle étape dans
l'est de l'Ukraine le positionnement de
l'imam au nord de l'oblastes de Donetsk
en fait un pivot dans la stratégie
ukrainienne de reconquête du don-basse
Kiev envisage de s'appuyer sur la ville
pour avancer vers l'Est avec en ligne de
mire c0k prise par les forces russes au
mois de juin au terme d'une terrible
bataille la prise de l'imam
constituerait un revers de taille pour
le Kremlin et montrerait la fragilité du
contrôle de Moscou sur ces territoires
annexés